[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
when called to the second date
unexpected presentation by the
distinguished speaker series year we are
honored to have with us today Steve Jobs
the president and chief executive
officer of next computer corporation
Steve has consistently been one of the
computer industries for most
entrepreneurs along with partners steve
bozniak
their entrance into the industry was by
the traditional entrepreneur route of
building computers in a garage such an
inauspicious start however so the
creation of Apple a formidable challenge
to IBM in the personal computer market a
true visionary Steve was known an early
age for his belief that a PC could be
put on every desk and made simple enough
for use educationally he had the right
credentials to make it big in a computer
industry because he dropped out of Reed
College a sapper guru the founders
original interest and a row in corporate
culture diverged both eventually left
Apple to establish their entrepreneurial
roots in 1985 he founded a new computer
company next corporation to design a
revolutionary computer computer called a
killer targeting the hiding workstation
market next has found they going tough
against entreated competitors such as
Sun Microsystems however with 1991
revenues hit in 127 million business has
grown substantially with the backing of
Ross Perot
next shouldn't be short of funds in the
future or in a more unlikely scenario a
friendly year in the White House
the current plans for next computer
involved a public offering possibly in
the next 14 months we hope to hear today
just what a good investment that should
be sting has consistently been
recognized for his contribution to
American largest high-tech industry most
recently he was appointed to the
President's Export Council last August
with a role to advise on government
policies and programs that affect trade
performance outside of works if his
marriage to Lorraine previously an MBA
student at Stanford University and also
a sister of one of our classmates
brought power the couple met when still
gave a similar speech to this
afternoon's at Stanford days before the
big area earthquake let's hope the
history doesn't repeat itself ladies and
gentlemen we are extremely grateful for
Steve to given up his time to be with us
this afternoon would you please give a
warm welcome to our distinguished guests
Steve
hi I guess we get to spend an hour or so
together today and most of the time I
wanted to spend just talking about what
you want to talk and answering some
questions but I I thought if you wanted
I'd take about 10 minutes or 15 minutes
up front and tell you what we're doing
it next and why the world might need
another computer company is that
something you guys think about these
things okay I thought I'd tell you about
some of our mistakes maybe that would be
more useful that we have a lot of scar
tissue William there's a really
interesting book that was written by a
guy named Paul Strassman and Paul has
one of the more interesting jobs in the
planet he's this chief information
officer cio a very large organization
called the Pentagon and they really
understand software there I had a
conversation with him not too long ago
when he said the lesson from the Gulf
War was that the best the best software
will win the war and so they're trying
to do a lot of work in the software area
and he wrote a book though before he got
this job called the business value of
computers it's rather thick and it's not
good bedtime reading but you can plow
through it and there's some incredible
stuff in it and what he asked two
questions in particular one was he
surveyed a bunch of companies from not
very successful all the way up through
really successful and there's somebody
taking notes here and he asked he asked
how much they spent on information
technology as a percentage of revenues
and he got a very counterintuitive
answer right you'd think that either the
really successful companies would either
spend more or less than the not
successful companies depending on your
theory but it was exactly the same they
all spent about two percent of revenues
on information technology and he found
this curious and so he asked another
question how do they spend their money
and he found out that the the really
successful ones actually will start with
a not so successful ones as we success
increases and dollars increase he found
out that the not so successful ones
spent the majority of their money
on management productivity and the more
successful one has spent the majority of
their money on operational productivity
applications right now this was not very
pleasant for me to read because I spent
the first ten years of my life on
management productivity which was PCs
right PCs and Macs never attacked
operational productivity they just
attacked management productivity why is
that because you can't go down to your
local computer store and buy an app that
will help you do stock trading or will
help you run a hospital or will help you
in whatever operational part of your
business you want to automate right
unless you're a very very small business
then you could run some accounting
packages but other than that if you were
medium-sized or large business these
things never attacked operational
productivity so we zoom out and we say
how if people attacked operational
productivity with information technology
well in the 60s they bought a mainframe
and they got some terminals and a bunch
of COBOL programmers and they wrote a
few apps and most of them were kind of
backroom apps and it sort of worked for
the very few that could afford to do
this in the 70s they got a mainframe and
some terminals and they did the same
thing and a few of them got a few mini
computers and terminals and tried to do
a little cheaper in the 80s nothing
changed mainframe in terminals minis and
terminals until maybe about two or three
years ago what happened two or three
years ago was that the front office
started to realize that they needed
operational apps so bad that they
couldn't depend on on the Mis folks
anymore and they started taking life
into their own hands and working with
sometimes working with the Mis folks to
start downsizing and getting some
servers and running some industry
standard databases like Sybase or Oracle
in the servers and making a little local
area network and getting maybe some Sun
workstations and spending about two
years writing some mission-critical
operational applications like trading
apps for Wall Street perfect example and
it kind of worked
and the reason that they needed to do
this was because more and more they were
discovering that things like new
products required a custom operational
application an example if you're in
financial services and you come up with
a new product it's only three things
it's an idea
it's a Salesforce and it's a custom app
to bang on databases to make the product
real to do the mortgage swaps or
whatever it is you want to do without
the app you don't have a product and so
there's been a increasing build-up of
demand from the front parts of
corporations to create more and more and
more of these operational applications
and I think it's going to get to the
point where this becomes fairly clear
that this is the next big revolution in
desktop computing is to create these
opera to attack the operational
productivity and as we start to
re-engineer the way we do things to
automate a lot of this in custom
applications it sounds a little strange
now to most people sounds like desktop
publishing did in 1985 nobody knew what
it was everybody thought it was kind of
a strange vertical thing over there but
my guess is it's pretty horizontal and
we're attacking vertical markets now
that know they want this and it's going
extremely well Sun is the only company
that's really had any success at this
and we're knocking them out of the box
because we came up with the software
called next step which lets you build
apps five to ten times faster than
anything anyone has ever seen and after
you build them they're deployable and
usable by mere mortals because it's
really easy to use this computer and you
can interoperate your custom apps
seamlessly with a bunch of off-the-shelf
productivity apps so we go to these
companies that use Suns and take two
years to write their apps or thinking
about using sense and they can write
their apps in about 90 days on the next
now if you're on Wall Street and you can
write you can create a new product in 90
days versus your competitor in two years
that's eight new products you can field
for there every one and you can start to
see
the competitive advantage that can be
created this way now we had no idea that
we were any good at this when we started
next a lot of times you don't know what
your competitive advantage is when you
launch a new product let me give you a
historical example when we created them
how many of you guys use Macs
good how many of you have seen it next
oh that's how many of you use it next
we'd like to change that ratio we're on
the right track anyway we when we
started when we did the Macintosh we
never anticipated desktop publishing
when we created the Mac sounds funny
because that turned out to be the Mac's
compelling advantage right the thing
that it did not one and a half or two
times better than everything else but
you know four or five times better than
anything else where you had to have one
we never anticipated it we anticipated
bitmap displays and laser printers but
we never thought about pagemaker that
whole industry really coming down to the
desktop maybe we weren't smart enough
but we were smart enough to see it start
to happen nine to twelve months later
and we changed our entire marketing and
business strategy
to focus on desktop publishing and it
became the Trojan horse that eventually
got the Mac into corporate America where
it could show its owners all the other
wonderful things you could do likewise
when we created next step this
revolutionary object-oriented software
that we have our target customer coming
from the PC world where shrink-wrapped
apps were king was Lotus and Adobe in
WordPerfect in all the shrink-wrap apps
developers and the purpose was to let
them create their apps 5 to 10 times
faster these shrink-wrapped apps and it
worked we have a ton of shrink-wrapped
apps now on Best of Breed in almost
every category but it wasn't till early
and 91 early last year a little over a
year ago that some really big companies
came to us and said you don't understand
what you've got the same software that
allows Lotus to create their apps 5 to
10 times
stur is letting us build our in-house
mission-critical apps five to ten times
faster and this is the biggest problem
we've had this is a huge problem for
every big company and almost all
medium-sized companies and you have the
solution in your hands and you dummies
don't even know it and it took him about
three months before we finally heard it
and in last summer we changed our whole
sales and marketing strategy around to
focus on that it's taken off like a
rocket and we grew about 4x last year
and probably grow about 2x this year and
our customer list is is now very very
strong and growing like crazy we just
got back from spending a few days in DC
and in New York and we're talking to
customers we only dreamed of talking to
a year ago so that's what we do and our
archenemies son they want to kill us
which is good they should try to do that
as soon as possible because the sooner
they do it the cheaper it will be for
them but they won't
I think it's gone past the point where
it's possible and they can't the
greatest thing is hardware's really
Hardware churns every 18 months it's
pretty impossible to get a sustainable
competitive advantage from hardware if
you're lucky you can make something one
and a half or two times as good as your
competitor which probably isn't enough
to be quite a competitive advantage and
it only lasts for six months but
software seems to take a lot longer for
people to catch up with I watched
Microsoft take eight or nine years to
catch up with the Mac and it's arguable
whether they've even caught up it takes
a long time and we think that the
soonest we're going to have a true
competitor is probably four to five
years so we've got that amount of time
to grow ourselves a one to two billion
dollar company so that we can compete
with them on scale see today we can't
compete with them on scale we never have
as many salespeople as they do as Sun
does we don't have the ad budgets that
they do so we've got to have a better
product assuming and I hope we always
have a better product and I think we can
but I'd also like to be able to at least
give them a run for their money on scale
so we've got the next three to four
years to run really fast so that by the
time they even get close to having a
competitive product we're at a large
enough scale to where we can start to
compete with them and that's what we're
doing with our lives right now spending
a lot of time with customers spending a
lot of time making next step better and
that kind of thing so that's the
strategic basis of what we do is that
make any sense to you
have you run across the concept of sort
of operational custom applications at
all I mean you guys most of you have
come from companies where you've had
work experience right and you all have
done that so if you you have this
problem in the companies you come from
of a lot of pressure to write these
operational custom applications and
hardly anything coming out of the spigot
to satisfy this thirst yeah how many of
you from Wall Street good
good
how many of you from manufacturing
companies Oh excellent
where are the rest of you from okay so
how many from consulting oh that's bad
yeah the mind is too important to waste
you should do something the only
consultants I've seen that I think are
truly useful are the ones that help us
sell our computers but other than that
no seriously III don't think there's
anything inherently evil and consulting
I think that I think that without
without owning something over an
extended period of time
like a few years where one has a chance
to take responsibility for one's
recommendations where one has to see
one's recommendations through all action
stages and accumulate scar tissue for
the mistakes and pick oneself up off the
ground and dust oneself off one learns a
fraction of what one can what you're you
coming in and making recommendations and
not owning the results not owning the
implementation I think is is a fraction
of the of the value and a fraction of
the opportunity to learn and get better
and so what what you you do get a broad
cut at companies but it's very thin it's
like a picture of a I would I could use
I'm vegetarian so when you stick it's
like a picture of a of a banana it you
might get a very accurate picture but
it's only two-dimensional and without
the experience of actually doing it you
never get three-dimensional so you might
have a lot of pictures on your walls you
can show it off to your friends you
can't
worked in bananas I've worked in peaches
I've worked in grapes but you never
really taste it and and I think that
that you're also a variable expense and
in hard times you find yourself you find
yourself variable right yes
[Music]
right very good question I'm gonna
generalize your question why don't we
just become a software company right
some very good questions the subtle
question we'll try to go through some
several things and I'm sorry if I jump
around we got a lot of requests from
customers last year that they would love
to see next step on other platforms and
primarily Intel based platforms like the
486 so we decided to do just that and we
have ported next step to the 486 and
we're finishing it now and it'll ship in
the September October time frame and
it's exactly the same stuff we run in
our own computer and same apps same user
interface same training same development
environment and we're gonna sell it for
995 and we're going it to a bunch of
companies whose names you'll recognize
quite easily and om get to them a much
cheaper price and everybody's coming out
of the woodwork to help us we're getting
help from Novell we're getting help from
all the developers Intel's really
helping us and they really want us to
succeed why is that right they all want
to make sure that there's a choice out
there and they're all really scared
about Microsoft and they see next step
as the only thing on the horizon that
can challenge Microsoft in system
software for the next several years so
we're enjoying a lot of help and you
know boy we need it so that's good now
we've also had a lot of requests from
companies to port next step to other
platforms and we're talking to some of
those company
right now now son we got a lot of
requests from son customers to port next
step to sons a lot of them are saying
look we we may not want to buy many more
but we already bought 500 we go and
throw them in the bay so can we put your
software now because Suns falling behind
in software now son says they'd rather
stick needles in their eyes than help us
do this that's a quote and so we're
evaluating right now which will be worse
for son if we poured it or if we don't
poured it and since we're fairly since
we're fairly customer driven we'll
probably end up doing what the customers
ask us to do now because we want to make
them happy now this leads one into the
question well this leads one of the
questions should we just be a software
company and we think the answer is no we
think we should be a software company
and a hardware company in making the
decision to put next step on more than
our own platforms we clearly decided
that we will sell less than a hundred
percent of the next step Hardware
however we think that the marketplace
will grow and we will sell more absolute
hardware and secondly the charter of our
hardware division is to make the best
next step hardware might not be the
cheapest might not be this might not be
that but we think all in all we can make
the best stuff and I would love it
nothing better than if someday we only
sold 20 or 25% of the next-step hardware
but I still think that's a billion
dollar plus hardware business and I'll
get into one other Hardware related
reason in a minute there's some things I
can't talk about here but it's
in addition to that if you look at how
we sell our computers right now we have
a sales force in the u.s. of about 130
professionals in the field out selling
next computers they spend 90% of their
time selling next-step software and then
10% of their time selling the hardware
in other words if they can get the
customer to buy into next step then
they're gonna sell the hardware because
right now we have the only hardware it
runs on so they are out there selling
next step right now and this is what is
required to launch a new innovative
product the current distribution
channels for the computer industry over
the last several years have lost their
ability to create demand they can
fulfill demand but they can't create it
if a new product comes out you're lucky
if you can find somebody at the computer
store to even knows how to demo it right
so the more innovative the product is
the more revolutionary it is and not
just an incremental improvement the more
you're stuck because the existing
channel is only fulfilling demand matter
of fact it's getting so bad that it's
getting wiped out because there are more
efficient channels to fulfill demand
like the telephone and Federal Express
so we're seeing that that the channel
become condensed on its way to I think
just televisions so how does one bring
innovation to the marketplace we believe
the only way we know how to do it right
now is with the direct sales force out
there in front of customers showing in
the products in the environment of their
own problems and discussing how those
problems can be mated with these
solutions a software-only company could
never afford to feel the direct sales
force with average selling prices of
$500 a software package you could never
afford 130 professionals in the field
with an average selling price of $5,000
you can and that's why I don't think
we're gonna see
anymore system software companies
succeed I don't think it's possible to
fund the effort to educate the market
about a revolutionary product with a
espies that low and if it's not a
revolutionary product I don't think the
company can succeed so our strategy has
been that we've got to be a hardware
company in order to make our software
business succeed and we think we can do
really well at both of them I know
that's a long answer but it's a complex
problem - yes
sure if you ask us who our competitors
are we'll say really three things three
one is Sun Solaris software the other is
Microsoft and the third is Tala gence
let's take him in that order son for a
while had a software value-added because
they have the best Unix in the
marketplace but the markets move way
beyond that and unfortunately Sun hasn't
so their software's falling further and
further behind and we while we take them
very seriously we don't think Solaris is
going to be much competition it's not
doesn't have an object in it and and
it's pretty much what they have today
Microsoft is doing NT which is their
sort of second attempt at a UNIX want to
be and that's great and I think it'll be
better than the last one which was os/2
but fundamentally it's just an operating
system it's better plumbing for Windows
it's a good way of thinking of it
unfortunately you still stuck with
Windows in all of its glory
including the worst development
environment that's ever been invented
and so we don't think that this is
really going to present a challenge to
what we're going after which are these
mission-critical custom apps because the
development environment is horrendous
it's not object oriented and even with
the better plumbing we think it will be
widely rejected for what we do in terms
of talent talent represents the first
true competitor that we could have
they're gonna ship a product around 1995
if they execute to their plans and I
think if they if they do execute to
their plans and work really hard by
about the mid-90s they'll have roughly
what we have today and that that's not
meant as a joke it still means we have
to run very hard because there they will
have a lot of resources at their
disposal I think there's a lot of
questions as to whether they will ever
ship a product I think they're a few
years away from having something running
unquote but we take them very seriously
now they've helped us enormous Lee
because they've blessed
object-oriented programming and right
now were the only folks that have it and
will be for the next 3-4 years so
if we can't compete with talent it's
probably because we've shot ourselves in
the foot you couldn't ask for something
better
IBM and Apple saying these guys are
right on track and come back in five
years and we'll have it - it's great and
so the balls in our Court yes well let's
get our terminology straight we look at
next step is an operating environment
much more than an operating system the
UNIX which is our operating system is
10% of next step so in these modern
operating environments when you develop
a custom app and next step it doesn't
run on the Mac or on Windows can't you
need all the objects that come with next
step to make it work and let me go into
a little detail there how many of you
are technical here a lot okay great
well we've discovered something you
don't write code any faster and next
step than you do in any other operating
and development environment that we know
of however to do a particular app on
average you write about 20% of the code
that you do in any other development
environment we know of about 20% of the
code then in Sun or anything else so the
code that's the fastest to write the
code that's the easiest to maintain and
the code that never breaks is the code
you don't write so that's our strategy
right a lot less code and one of the
ways of the way we do this is we enable
the developer to use
a lot of objects that others have
written we ship six years worth of
objects with next step you can create
your own objects for your own company
and then reuse them around your
developers and there's now independent
third party companies not selling system
software not selling applications but
selling objects
there's about it not quite ten of them
and it's starting and I think it's going
to be very big thing so in order to
deliver these apps that are created on
next step you have to have next step so
they can run on top and take advantage
of this rich community of objects and
that's why we're porting next step to
the 486 that's why you'll see next step
running on several hardware platforms
and will there be a fracturing if you
will sure to some extent there will and
I tend to look at it as a transition was
there a fracturing when Mac came out yes
and there's been more of a transition as
people either move to Mac or in the case
of Windows adopt what's good about the
Mac same things gonna happen here
we believe very strongly with the
benefits from these object oriented
environments not only just rapid
development but a much richer user
environment if you use a next it's a lot
nicer than a Mac or a PC even if you've
never developed an app other
environments will absorb some of those
breakthroughs and more and more people
will use next step and things will tend
to balance themselves out over time but
there will be a transition and our goal
is to make sure we're part of it yeah
good question if our business strategy
says that we do a lot of things well but
the tip of our arrow or our Trojan horse
which is getting us into these large and
medium-sized accounts is our custom
application development ability then our
growth is going to be paced among other
things by the development community
available to these companies to develop
these apps right now even though we have
shrunk the development time down to a
fraction of what it was still without
developers out there we're not going to
win fortunately most companies have
really increased the staffs of good
people in there is departments
dramatically in the last several years
last four or five years there's now
really bright people who know something
about computer science and is
departments and most of the industries
we talk to whether they're healthcare
financial services even law enforcement
places like that have on-site developers
in there is teams if not they're
starting to become a lot of VARs and
people out there that we're using in LA
or in New York right just was we
probably have about ten independent
third-party companies helping parts of
Wall Street develop things so I think
that's not going to be a stumbling block
my personal opinion is the number of
people in applications development is
shrinking it exploded in in the 80s with
PCs but now that industry is
consolidating its consolidating down to
very few companies and there's a lot of
excess people out there that I think are
starting to get channeled into some of
these other areas so so far it hasn't
been a problem but if you know if you
want to do that please call us and tell
us because we always need more so what
are you guys all gonna do when you get
out of you're gonna go back to your
companies is that how many you gonna go
back how many aren't you're gonna go
back what are you gonna do
well yeah I think we always have jobs
for really smart technical people you
know technically based people and you
guys are getting a great business
education here yeah we'd love to talk to
Lonnie yeah yes sir go ahead well these
are deep questions
I tell you I I've obviously thought
about this a lot and I don't wanna get
into it too much but I will say that
that I think everybody lost I think I
lost and I have wanted to spend my life
there I think Apple lost I think
customers lost and having said all that
so what you go on you know it's not as
bad as a lot of things not as bad as you
know losing your arm so people go on and
companies go on and I think Apple I'm
very happy every time Apple ships a Mac
makes me very very happy I think the
power books are decent products I like
them but Apple has been struggling the
last few years they've been having a
real struggle with who they want to be
and and this is nothing new we always
had that that was part of what kept
Apple alive I think and there were two
camps with an apple camp one wanted to
be the next serious computer company and
camp two wanted to sort of be the Sony
of computers and that struggling I think
was somewhat tearing Apple apart and
fortunately the Sony guys of one they've
kind of decided to go be than the Sony
of computers and so the power books are
pretty good but the quadrazine Oh suck
wind right now the high-end stuff and
their abdicating they're basically not
putting a lot of resources on to the
power users on desktops and they've
they've put most of their best people
now on the portables and on consumer
products that they're gonna be coming
out with and I think they'll do very
well at that now there's a problem in
there in that if you look at the
consumer products that sell over a
million a year you can count them on a
few hands right it turns out there's no
I mean consumer electronics products not
like toothbrushes but but electronics
prices and so let's assume they have one
of those right or two of those let's say
they have a product sells two million a
year and at a $500 ASP to them so it
sells to the consumer at you know 795 or
something like that now that's a hundred
that's what a billion dollars right two
million a year five hundred bucks
it's a billion dollars they still have
to get the other seven billion in
revenue somewhere so it's going to be an
interesting transition as the ASP s get
lower the volumes have to get much much
higher and you run into some scale
issues when you look out at the consumer
electronics industry not that it's not
possible and I think it's be really
interesting to watch and we also see a
lot of that's not quite that clarity of
movement but some movement in the
Windows and PC world again towards
taking what they have now and making it
portable but not giving the top third of
the market more power you know system
seven on the Mac was supposed to be the
second coming and it wasn't it turned
out to be you know an incremental
improvement os/2 was supposed to take us
into new dimensions and it turned out to
be a complete failure and they're gonna
throw another 100 million dollars after
it just to make sure you all know about
it and so there's a third of those
desktops out there that the users and
the people that want to deploy more
sophisticated apps are there in the
desert wanting something to drink and I
think there's a tremendous opportunity
to give them some solutions now that
doesn't mean that Apple's not going to
be successful just means they're gonna
go off in another direction
do what who knows what would have
happened you know had had all this not
happened so yes I'm in the corner
[Music]
sure yeah we've done a lot in the last
year the most significant things we did
were one we hired this guy right here
Mike Slade is our VP of Marketing
he spent standup
[Laughter]
and he's cheap too and Mike Mike spent
seven or eight years at Microsoft and I
originally met him he was the product
manager for excel when it first came out
and end up running big pieces and
marketing for Microsoft so Mike runs all
the marketing it next and Mike came in
to next just about the time when we were
finally hearing what these big companies
were saying about mission-critical
custom apps and so we've worked very
closely together to redefine the
marketing strategy of the company and
mike has done just a superb job at that
the second big thing we did was about
three months ago a little over three
months ago we consolidated our hardware
design engineering our manufacturing our
worldwide distribution and hardware
service all into one chunk called the
hardware division so from cradle to
grave they have Hardware
responsibilities and we're in the
process of forming the software division
right now so that we're all still under
the same roof but we have clarity about
the fact that we've got to make two
businesses successful the third thing
that we did was and we have a really
great person running that rich page
who's one of the founders of next he's
doing a great job running that we hired
a new CFO recently Marcel Ghani
he's from Intel spent 12 years at Intel
doing some pretty interesting jobs he
ran all the finance for Europe he ran
all of internal audit for the board he
ran all of manufacturing planning and
scheduling for a while and things like
that he's a pretty good guy went to
Cyprus for a year and a half and then
came to next and he's he's great and
then recently mad fact about last week
I hired a chief operating officer guy
named Peter van caelum Berg and Peter is
someone I first met when we were looking
for an executive vice president the
sales and marketing and he turned me
down for the job and we subsequently
decided not to hire that position and
I've been chasing him for the last year
and a half almost he's really good he he
spent a lot of time at TI as run Europe
and about three years ago went to
company called mercury communications in
England they're the mci of the UK and
turn that company around to about two
billion dollars and then was promoted to
run half of cable and while or half of
Mercury's parent company Cable and
Wireless and was running there about six
billion dollars and he went there when
he thought that communications and
computing were gonna kind of come
together but never happened and he
figured out that his real love is in the
computer business he's very very good
operationally so that's just happened
last week it seems like all the good
people I really want to hire it seems to
take me a year to hire him and it's
always been that way even at Apple some
of the best technical people or whoever
it always seemed to take me like a year
to pry them out of HP or wherever and
took me it took me over a year to high
mining mike has the award you're about a
year and a half and they're all worth it
what happens is I usually meet somebody
that is really good I think is very very
good and you can't get them and then you
go try to find other people and you know
nobody measures up you know when you
meet somebody that good just you always
compare them this one person you know
you're gonna be settling for second best
if you compromise and I've always found
it best not to compromise and just keep
chipping away so I think we're doing
quite a bit feels like we're running a
company a lot better now than we ever
have we've definitely made our share of
mistakes yeah
I'll give you a global answer than we
need ascend into some details I believe
that you can use the concept of Technol
technology windows opening you know and
then eventually closing but and what I
mean by that is enough technology
usually from fairly diverse places comes
together and makes something that's a
quantum leap forward possible and it
doesn't come out of nowhere if you poke
around the labs and you hang around you
know the media lab here at MIT and other
places you can kind of get a feel for
some of those things and usually they're
not quite possible but all of a sudden
you start to sense things coming
together and the planets lining up to
where this is now possible or barely
possible and a window opens up and it
usually takes around my experience
anyway my life has been it takes around
five years to create a commercial
product that takes advantage of that
technical window opening up sometimes
you start before the window is quite
open and you can't get through it you
push it up and you push it up sometimes
just takes a lot of work it took that
long you know with the Apple to took
that long with the Mac you know took a
Lisa
along the way one hundred million
dollars it takes a why it's a lot
expensive to push those windows open
they're missing and in our case you know
our first product failed we came out
with this cube and we sold 10,000 of
them why because we weren't quite there
yet and we made some mistakes along the
way and we had to course-correct
you know macintosh was a course
correction off the Lisa so with Apple
two and three we did it in Reverse but
the
it takes around five years or some
number of years like that to realize
that window opening and then it seems to
take about another five years to really
exploit it in the marketplace and let me
give you some examples in from my life
Apple two lasted 15 years 15 years the
hard work churned but basically it was
the same for 15 years dass you know dass
just past ten years I don't think anyone
would disagree that it's gonna easily
last another five right unfortunately
and Mac you know Mac is eight years old
right no question it's gonna last
another four or five years right these
things are hard it's not they don't last
because it's convenient or even because
it's economic it last cuz they're really
hot this is hard stuff to do and so when
we are pushing that window open I think
with our current generation of products
we finally got the window open after six
years it's open we've got an extremely
elegant implementation and we've got
five years of work to do to exploit it
in the marketplace and when you know
will peak in five years five years we'll
all sit around say okay it's time to get
started on the next thing it's time to
get going on the next thing maybe four
years from now but we've got a lot of
work ahead of us just to move this thing
out and educate the market and continue
to refine it based on market feedback so
everything I know about technology
windows that are open or just about open
is in next step or we're working on it
in the labs and these things generally
don't come along independently they kind
of clumps of them come together it's
been my experience so the things that
aren't in there right now that I can
talk about there's there's some video
stuff that's really interesting that
it's going to be integrated in there's
some security stuff that's really
fascinating that's integrating in but
most of the core technologies in their
products are getting smaller and
portable products are getting much much
faster but these things are well known
you know the products that we can put on
that we can give to you in the next in
the next year or two are gonna be
running at speeds
that I find hard to believe and I've
been doing this for a while
so I think the windows open and and I
think object-oriented technology is the
biggest technical breakthrough I have
seen since the early 80s with with
graphical user interfaces and I think
it's bigger actually proved to be bigger
over a software company
well the Microsoft's made it easy
I'm sorry the question is if you're a
software company should you develop apps
or shoot you to develop objects and
tools and see the software industry with
Microsoft and Lotus and we're perfect
made it real easy unless you've got 20
or 30 million dollars burning a hole in
your pocket so you can go out and hire a
few hundred people to develop what it
takes to develop one of these polished
shrink-wrapped apps on Mac or on Windows
then you don't have much of a choice
there's not a real opportunity there -
assuming you had the best spreadsheet
today you could easily spend fifty
million dollars marketing it before
you'd be breaking even selling it
because of just how expensive it is to
market a product today right
well assume that you have a breakthrough
spreadsheet again on mainstream
platforms it'll take you 15 million 50
million dollars to just rise above the
noise noise level and market it so what
the brightest people I know of today are
doing is they're writing objects they're
writing hunks of things that other
developers are going to use to build
apps and they're going where where
everybody isn't and that's I think going
to be the next new thing yeah I think
your question is what is our philosophy
on marketing our products to higher
education well we started off selling
only to higher education which which
arguably was a mistake and but we've
done really well they're in our hearts
are there and we sold a lot of
Macintosh's there too and we were to
Apple and I think it's a no-brainer
I think you take your products you
discount them as heavily as you can you
sell them into higher education higher
education is a wonderful place to give
you great feedback about how to make
your products better and what's wrong
with them and it's a great place to
educate bright people that you can hire
and that your customers can hire when
they graduate so we do exactly that we
have I think we're sold on about 350
campuses in the United States we are
clearly the number one selling work
station across the US and we're the
number two selling computer of any type
at campuses like here MIT or Stanford
right behind the Macintosh we sell more
computers at MIT than PCs through the
institutional resale engines so we do we
do as much as we can and I think it's
been pretty effective what do you think
right well what's happening is the
project the thiness didn't succeed for a
reason they didn't succeed because they
had a lot of good ideas as a research
project but the people necessary to
commercialize those things and make them
into real products aren't necessarily
the same people that are going to
pioneer the ideas at a university like
MIT and so those projects never quite
get baked the the recipes kind of
developed and they you make a few
samples and it's pretty good but the
computer industry is pretty advanced and
so other people pick up those ideas and
make them into real products and they
kind of leave the research projects in
the dust if the researchers drop
research and start trying to
commercialize stuff and I can point to a
hundred examples of that in higher
education so it's probably good that
project Athena has a beginning a middle
and an end so that those people don't
get stuck trying to do commercial
software in an academic environment it's
kind of a mismatch as far as we're
concerned what what we're doing is
there's a lot of labs that are being put
in in higher education and we're winning
almost every one of those and we really
go hard after the lab so that people
that can't afford the computers have
have public access and most universities
now have fairly elaborate campus-wide
networks it's not no longer a new
cutting-edge thing and we plug right
into those so I I think it's life's
moved beyond where it was a few years
ago where those kind of projects were
really important and and the knowledge
to do that is exists fairly widespread a
few more yeah
good question
[Music]
I'm not sure I learned this when I was
at Apple but I learned it based on the
data when I was at Apple and that is I
now take a longer-term view on people in
other words when I see something not
being done right my first reaction isn't
to go fix it it's to say we're building
a team here and we're gonna do great
stuff for the next decade not just the
next year and so what do I need to do to
help so that the person that's screwing
up learns versus how do I fix the
problem and that's painful sometimes and
my and I still have that first instinct
to go fix the problem but that's taking
a longer-term view on people it's
probably the biggest thing that's
changed and then I don't know that's you
know maybe the part that's biological
yes management what's her management
style how do we resolve conflict I've
never believed in the theory that if
we're on the same management team and a
decision has to be made and I decide in
a way that you don't like and I say come
on buy into the decision you know buy
into it like we're all on the same team
you don't agree but buy into it let's go
make it happen
because what happens is sooner or later
you're paying somebody to do what they
think is right but then you're trying to
get them to do what they think isn't
right and it ends sooner or later it
outs and you you end up having that
conflict so I've always felt that the
best way is to get everybody in a room
and talk it through until you agree now
that's not everybody in the company but
that's everybody that's really involved
in that decision that needs to execute
it and so that's how we try to run next
the way we run next is we have a team at
the top we call the policy team there's
eight people mike is on it I'm on it we
have six other people on it and the key
this we have two things we try to do one
is we try to differentiate between the
really important decisions and the ones
that we don't have to make and the
really important ones we work on it till
we all agree because we're paying people
to tell us what to do there is I don't
view that we pay people to do things
that's easy to find people to do things
what's harder is to find people to tell
you what should be done right that's
what we look for so we pay people a lot
of money and we expect them to tell us
what to do and so when you when that's
your attitude you shouldn't run off and
do things if people don't all feel good
about them and and the key to making
that work is to realize there's not that
many things that any one team really has
to decide and we might have 25 really
important things we have to decide on a
year not a lot
so that's that's how we try to run it
sometimes it works and sometimes we're
still working on it I can't think of
once I can't maybe there's once or twice
but I I can't even recall a time when
I've said dammit I'm the CEO and we're
doing it this way you know I can't
recall a time when I've said we don't
see eye to eye and you're off the team
I've had to say that once or twice over
a prolonged period of time when a person
has not wanted to go in the same
direction we've wanted to go in as a
team but it's my job every once in a
while to say hey you want to go this way
we want to go this way
it's not working so but when people are
on the team then we work it out yeah
[Music]
I want to come back to your premium
product characterization because our
products actually cost you know close to
half of what sons do and the reason they
do is is we have the most automated
Factory in the industry and we have a
great VLSI design group which designs
stuff in a lot less part do you guys
manufacturing do you care about that we
should talk about that in a minute
the industry is bifurcating right now
and what's happening is is that the max
and the PCs is you know in the day are
all gonna be just like this hold up your
power book all gonna be just like this
only lighter and smaller before very
long and they're taking the technology
we have today
not particularly changing it and getting
it off the desktop and portable forms
and they're giving up a few things for
that but nothing terribly profound
however we're getting all sorts of
signals from certain parts of the
markets that they want things that are
the enemy of that right well what are
they well speed speed is the enemy of
portability because speed takes power
right so the kind of speed that our
customers want it would run for three
and a half minutes on batteries that's
useless
the second thing they want is they want
a lot more storage on their disk drives
and a lot more memory again the enemy of
portability for power and size reasons
another thing they want is really high
speed networking right the radio lands
on these things at best are gonna go
nineteen to kill a bits per second our
customers want a hundred megabits per
second and higher you're not gonna do
that with a radio LAN anytime in the
next five years another thing our
customers want is our mix is shifted to
like 80 percent color and they want true
color to do photographs there is no flat
panel color display today that will do
photographic quality color and they want
big ones because once you have
multitasking you can run a bunch of
things once you need a bigger window
into this electronic world when you're
using your computer for two or three
hours a day you don't want to be looking
you know through blinders this big you
want something bigger so these are all
the enemy of that today and we're
working on smaller products for sure but
it's it's really tough to get both and
we're optimizing for the power because
we see a giant hole there for running
these mission-critical custom apps and
what people are doing needs more power
so that's that's what we're optimizing
for well you know let's talk about
manufacturing how many of you have a
manufacturing background oh that's great
I love manufacturing and what kinds of
things what kinds of companies you have
pharmaceuticals any auto people here
auto electronics which ti uh-huh
Motorola
I heard that remember - no couldn't be
further from the truth
we we love manufacturing it next and
when I was at Apple I had the good
fortune to lead the effort to build the
Mac Factory and we designed and built
and operated that Factory and it was a
real breakthrough it was the best
factory in the industry - we built the
one it next and we made a lot of it we
made a lot of mistakes though as an
example I remember walking through it
you know one of the things you learn
when you start building factories is
that warehouses are really bad right
warehouses are bad because you tend to
put things in them and inventory is
really bad inventory is really bad
because if it's defective you don't find
out about it for a while and you don't
close the quality feedback loop with a
vendor and correct the problem until
they've made a zillion of them what you
want to do is find the problem the first
one that comes in the door and stop them
from making more until you fix the
problem so warehouse has also cost money
because you put all the stuff in them in
the stuff you have to go borrow from the
bank or use money that could be you know
used in a more productive purpose so
warehouses are bad and you want to go to
JIT J I'm sure you've studied this all
and studied examples I was walking
through the Mack factory when they the
two biggest pieces of automation we put
in were a giant small parts storage and
retrieval system was these totes that
ran around and that the second one was
this giant burnin system at the end and
you know a few tens of millions of
dollars worth of equipment and I
realized unfortunately too late that
both of them are warehouses they're just
high tech warehouses right and so when
we looked at next we said no warehouses
of any kind we have a true JIT factory
stuff comes in and is delivered right to
the point of use on the factory floor
there is no warehouse deliveries are
made daily sometimes more frequently
than that there is no outgoing warehouse
everything is visible and
the reason that we were able to do a lot
of what we've done is because we looked
at manual I'm given example when we were
learning about manufacturing in Mac we
hired a Stanford Business School
professor at the time named Steven
wheelwright who Harvard's since stolen
away I think and he did a neat thing he
drew on the board a little chart first
time I met him he said you can view all
companies from a manufacturing
perspective this way you can say there's
five stages one two three four five
right they all have these things Stage
one is companies that view manufacturing
as a necessary evil
they wish they didn't have to do it but
damn it they do and all the way up
through stage 5 which is companies that
view manufacturing is a competitive
opportunity for competitive advantage
right we can get better time to market
and get new products out faster we get
lower cost we get higher quality and in
general you know you can sort of put the
American flag here
with the Japanese when I'm here and
that's changing however that's changing
and and it's changing as people like you
are going into manufacturing companies
are starting to realize that we were
great at this one time and then we took
it for granted and people are starting
to pay good salaries now and get good
people and so we want to be one of these
and we try very hard by the way just
going back to software for a minute I
often apply the scale to computer
companies and how they look at software
C I think most computer companies are
stage one they wish software had never
been invented
I put compact in that category and IBM's
may be stage two and things like that
and I think there's only there's only
calm you know Suns may be sort of in the
middle maybe here I think there's only
three companies here and that's us Apple
and Microsoft in stage five we start
everything with the software and work
back but anyway going back to
manufacturing we started looking at the
factory as a software problem and the
first people we hired in the factory
were some software engineers we
convinced them to move from R&D into
software which was not easy we had to
give him bonuses we had to cajole him we
had to promise them they could come back
if they hated it and they went over
there and we said this is really just a
software problem with interesting i/o
devices called robots that's all it is
and so we started building the software
first and our first robots that we got
we expect them out and we bought them
completely turnkey with the robot arms
on them and all the electronics and the
software to control them and we SPECT it
out but we didn't write it and they
didn't they worked ok some of them are
still in use but they weren't great and
being software folks we weren't real
happy they weren't they weren't elegant
we couldn't do what we wanted with the
robots we couldn't tie in a quality
information system to them and all this
other stuff we wanted so the second
generation we Specht out the hardware
and had somebody build the hardware for
us but we wrote all the software on our
own computers we're object-oriented so
we started writing robot objects quality
objects you know all sorts of objects to
control
this Factory and we found out our
computer was great for it and so our
whole Factory now runs on this
object-oriented factory and quality
system the last generation of our latest
generation of robots which we've
deployed this year we actually built the
hardware I've been to Japan maybe a lot
of times maybe 3040 times and I loved -
or factories over there and I they
always amazed me because they'd built
everything themselves they weren't
afraid of anything they needed a robot
they try to buy one but if they couldn't
they'd actually engineer it and build it
and you'd think this was really
expensive but we found out it's pretty
cheap it's actually cheaper than buying
them and so we've actually now designed
our inspect out around robots we don't
mill the metal or anything we get that
all maybe we put them all together and
we do the software top-to-bottom and we
have now some extraordinarily advanced
robots in the factory and our computers
are built start to finish on the on the
key components completely untouched by
human hands so we're pretty convinced
we're the low-cost producer we do it in
Fremont California right under our nose
and we export them to Japan and all
sorts of other places and Cannon is our
partner in Japan and they they do very
very thorough quality audits and we're
now at the point where we're directly
shipped to stock with them and they say
we're a very high quality supplier so
yeah they can well we don't get very
permission to do that but yes they can
here's how it works um one of the things
we do is we actually when we want to
build an engineering prototype see what
happens in most one of the key things
that manufacturing can contribute to
competitive advantage is time to market
why is that because the way most things
work is you design your product here and
after you're done you throw it over the
wall and you design your manufacturing
process here right sorting out a bunch
of things that maybe weren't done right
here fixing them changing them and then
completing the process design what you
want to do is do this and ship it right
here while your competitors are still
here and that's what we've been able to
do in many cases what we do is we suck
data out of our CAD systems in
engineering we zing them around over the
local networks over a t1 - free
manufacturers about 15 minutes away and
in our own computers we compute all of
the robot placement programs fully
optimized path we compute all the vision
system programs we check it against the
Bill of Materials in the is system and
we download it to the robots and we're
ready to build a board lot size of one
in between two production CPU boards on
the line full surface mount with all of
our automation technology now the key is
that manufacturing did that so well for
engineering that we haven't built a
prototype in engineering for two years
we haven't built a wire wrap or any
other kind of prototype in engineering
for two years everything has been built
in the factory now what does that mean
what that means is manufacturing gets
involved from day one right because the
fact that the engineering guys call it
manufacture go hey we want to build a
prototype we're gonna need these special
parts on the thing take a look at this
tell us what you think we'd like to do
it tomorrow let us know if that's okay
blah blah blah they get involved from
day one and what it also means is so we
get this parallelism secondly a lot of
times when you build prototypes it's not
quite the same technology as you're
going to use in production and so all
the accumulated knowledge you
from building your prototypes you throw
away when you change technology to go
into production and you start over in
that accumulation process because we
don't change technology we don't throw
anything away we don't waste time and
it's led to one of the healthiest
relationships between an engineering and
manufacturing group I've ever seen in my
life they're all working off the same
databases they're all working on the
same processes they're all working in a
very disciplined process environment to
where when any processes are changed
they all get together and and review the
proposals and all buy into it and it's
not that hard the the the key to it all
though was we didn't go out and hire a
bunch of manufacturing people we went
out and hired engineers and we convinced
them that we were going to be different
we're gonna pay them exactly the same as
metric we paid them a little more at the
beginning but we pay them exactly the
same as R&D no different there's
migration both directions not just from
manufacturing into R&D but both
directions and they're not second-class
citizens they have the same offices they
have the same test equipment they have
the same computers on their desks and it
took us a while to convince him that we
were really serious and until for about
the first few years we had more PhDs in
manufacturing than we did design
engineering until design engineering
stole a few of my way so it's it's
really paid off for us and I think it's
one of our real opportunities for
competitive advantage yeah I think one
or two more and we've got a run and
probably you do too
yes up there time
yeah how are we getting our raw
materials you mean like what truck line
brings them in or what do you see the
key thing is that's not our problem
that's our suppliers problem so we agree
with our supplier when the stuff is
going to arrive on our factory floor and
if they can if they're together enough
to ship it by truck that's fine if they
have to ship it by air that's too bad if
they want to have a warehouse next to
ours because they're not good enough
well then they have to do that now we're
not giant so we can't go command people
to do things but what's happened is is
we have a fairly narrow supply base we
we don't have three billion suppliers
and they see tremendous advantages in
working with us
we're pushing our quality information
systems back to them as an example
Motorola is one of our key suppliers
almost every key supplier has next
computers and we send them statistical
quality information sometimes daily
daily offer automated quality
information systems on their parts and
those kinds of things are extremely
valuable to them so while we're not
we're not Goliath we're a very valuable
David to work with and so they really
bend over backwards to work with us and
we try to push the problems where they
belong if it's our problems we take full
responsibility for them we own our
process but they it's their job to get
us zero defect material on time per
agreements and our philosophy is our
money doesn't break after we give it to
them so their part shouldn't break after
they'd given us
[Applause]
yeah y-you know I think Mac's are gonna
continue to grow it depends on what
Apple does I think certain segments of
the Mac market are going to continue to
grow I think certain segments of the Mac
market are not going to be be targeted
for future growth and having Mac's are
good computers to do certain things but
to do the things that people I think are
gonna want to do in a few years I don't
think you can do them on a Mac I don't
think you can do them on Dawson windows
and so I think there's a need for some
new technology just like you know
there's a lot of things that you could
do on Dass when the Mac came out but
there was some new things you just
couldn't and it would take a long time
and I think the same way with the Mac
hey we have to head off into the sunset
back to California but thanks for a
chance to be with you all for some time
[Applause]